[Music]
the U.S government seized First Republic
Bank on May 1st and struck a deal to
sell the bulk of its operations to JP
Morgan Regulators hope the move will
head off a chaotic collapse that could
reignite the banking crisis no way Ben
Eisen covers Banking and finance for the
journal he explains how First Republic
became the second largest bank to fail
in the U.S and what it means for
customers investors and the industry
first Republican of this business model
that is just sort of perfectly built for
a certain time period when interest
rates were really low the bank collected
a lot of deposits that made a lot of
mortgages but when rates suddenly
shifted last year the bank's business
model started to look a little bit more
precarious after Silicon Valley Bank and
signature failed in March everyone
pretty much immediately started looking
to First Republic as the next risky Bank
in the system
Silicon Valley Bank and First Republic
they had similar enough client bases and
similar enough risks and problems that
investors and customers and really
anyone in this banking crisis started to
kind of lump them together some of the
biggest banks collected 30 billion
dollars worth of their own money and
they deposited it at First Republic Bank
basically trying to make up for the
deposits that customers had pulled it
was helpful for her day but it didn't
stop the panic
coming into April 24th versus republic
was already in a pretty bad spot after
the bank released its earnings and and
really didn't impress people with with
what it showed at this period of time
when the stock was falling really
rapidly there was a sense that this bank
was increasingly at risk of being seized
early in the morning of May 1st an
announcement came out that JP Morgan
would be buying First Republic Bank this
was a deal that was orchestrated by the
Federal Deposit Insurance Corp when the
FDIC conducts this process to sale a
bank that it's using it's basically
looking for the best Bid And in the deal
JP Morgan will be taking on some 92
billion dollars in deposits from First
Republic buying a lot of assets
including the banks loans and bonds
shareholders will get wiped out this is
a deal that will effectively allow First
Republic to live on as a part of
JPMorgan let me be very clear all
depositors are being protected
shareholders are losing their
Investments and critically taxpayers are
not the ones that are on the hook
the resolution for First Republic
appears to be the end of this stage of
the banking crisis that said the
problems that kind of led to this crisis
haven't necessarily been resolved
interest rates Rose really quickly the
value of assets on banks balance sheets
fell a lot it doesn't appear that
anything's imminent at this moment but I
think a lot of people would be hesitant
to say this is over
foreign